hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with another youtube
tips episode so thumbs up for that and
this is actually a video featuring my
good friend duncan 33303 austin evans so
if you'd like to check out his channel
bam it's right there you can visit the
other half of this video which will show
you some more of these youtube tips that
we're going over to create better videos
so we're going to start off with is the
more off camera things in this video in
the other video we talked about the
camera itself the first thing i'm going
to talk about is sound and you might see
my microphone right here the first thing
we talked about in terms of sound is
what type of microphone you're using so
we'll start with a usb microphone a
youtube favorite for usb microphones is
the blue snowball very very popular
you'll see this all over youtube people
really enjoy the convenience of having
it just sit right on your desk plug it
right in and play literally plug and
play and just go right there so it's a
very popular choice and you even get
some options on the back for changing
the patterns the second option for a
microphone would be something that
mounts directly on the top of the the
hot shoe of the camera itself a lot of
canon dslrs and canon camcorders have a
microphone jack so the most popular i
think youtube on camera mic is the rode
video mic you've probably seen this
before just mouse right on top of the
camera in the hot shoe and is a very
popular option for those of you guys who
get a camera with a microphone input and
last but not least there's a completely
off-camera stuff that literally sits
next to you and you can position
wherever you want not connected to a
computer and the number one option for
that would be the zoom h1 now you do
have to post products you literally have
to go back and sync the audio in post
production that's a step you don't have
to do usually with on camera microphones
or usually with usb microphones so if
you do prefer to have the most control
over where you put your microphone and
how much volume you get out of it the
zoom h1 is a great option and very
popular for youtube one of the best
parts of having a dslr is the
interchangeable lenses what this means
is you can swap out the lens for
whatever you want so for example i'm
shooting right here prime lens is going
to be nice if i'm going to be doing a
lot of zooming of course the super zoom
is going to be good if you just want to
get by cheaply the kit lens on your
camera is going to be just fine however
for video i really like having a prime
lens so for my pick on a canon it would
be the 50 millimeter 1.8 now this is a
absolutely cheap lens it's built cheaply
it's called the plastic fantastic
however it is fantastic so you're going
to get some really nice depth of field
and it's going to get some pretty sharp
images for the price likewise if you
like nikon cameras the nikon 50mm
50mm 1.8 is also going to be a good
choice now both of these lenses are not
going to be absolutely superb you can
absolutely get better as you spend more
money but for a relatively reasonable
budget both of these are going to be
really good for filming youtube videos
so lighting's a pretty popular option
also uh and in terms of youtube videos
you typically the more light the better
you like to be able to see your subject
and three-point lighting is the most
popular way to get your videos lit so
say you're lighting an object you can
take advantage before you buy anything
of a lot of free light lights free you
know comes from the sun you can use some
windows that you have you can use a
video light that's completely out of the
range you know you can have a light just
from the top of your room and once you
get all those lights on you just want to
make sure you have a pretty accurate
color representation before you go out
and buy more lights if you do choose to
buy lights there are some very
inexpensive light kits from things like
amazon and some even dedicated retailers
for video stuff but i suggest that
before you go out and buy lights you
take advantage of as much free light as
possible that's going to help you out a
lot of course at the end of the day no
matter what equipment you have you're
going to need to edit your videos and my
recommendation if you're on windows is
to check out coral video studio pro x4
so i've been using video studio for the
past couple years now while it's
certainly not going to be as advanced as
something like sony vegas it's also
going to be a lot cheaper and a lot
simpler to use so it does have plenty of
power with all kinds of picture and
picture support chroma key everything
that you'd really need of course it's a
much cheaper price point it should run
pretty nicely on most computers on a mac
i recommend imovie now a lot of people
kind of dismiss imovie but i think it's
a little unfair well sure yes it is free
and it does come with all macs that's
not to say that's not any good so imovie
does of course support a lot of the same
things that video studio does a lot of
the kind of mid-range features that most
people would need but not a lot of the
really extreme stuff that stuff like
final cut has that's going to cost
obviously a lot more than free so that's
basically it for this youtube tips
episode but keep in mind this is only
part one so like i said before you can
check out part two whenever you want is
probably done watching this video now so
check out part two on austin's channel
duncan 33303 and you can subscribe to
him as well thanks for watching guys and
i'll talk to you later
peace
you